un total de 20 hombres son sospechosos
de desempeñar papeles clave en los
atentados terroristas de noviembre de
2015 en París 14 de Ellos están en el
banquillo de los acusados 14 de los
hombres supervivientes fueron juzgados
en la sala especial penal de París por
su participación la noche del 13 de
noviembre entre ellos el único
superviviente de las tres bandas
yihadistas que protagonizaron los
atentados en todo París
abdeslam hombres de entre 28 y 39 años
entre ellos el amigo de la infancia de
slam Mohamed abrini apodado el hombre
del sombrero abril y fue acusado de
haber proporcionado armas y apoyo
logístico Durante los atentados de
noviembre antes de huir a Bélgica donde
decidió a último momento no inmolarse
Durante los atentados de marzo de 2016
en Bruselas estos acusados fueron
procesados por varios delitos entre
ellos participación en una organización
terrorista complicidad en asesinato
complicidad en tentativa de asesinato
complicidad en de asesinato de personas
que ocupan cargos de autoridad pública
el fiscal ha pedido cadena perpetua
completa para teslam una pena que solo
se ha impuesto cuatro veces en Francia
desde 2007 Para abril y los fiscales han
pedido la cadena perpetua con un mínimo
de 22 años de prisión se pidieron penas
más leves de 5 años de prisión para los
acusados de haber ayudado a app de slam
a escapar y seis hombres fueron juzgados
en ausencia de ellos se cree que 5 están
muertos entre ellos se usa matar
considerado uno de los arquitectos de la
masacre así como los miembros del estado
islámico Fabián Israel Michael Klan la
duración del juicio y el número de
demandantes lo han convertido en el caso
judicial más impactante de la historia
de Francia